bonjour il n'y a pas si longtemps je
voudrais c'est le portrait de harga
thomann une femme bien badass qui avait
sauvé beaucoup d'esclaves ensuite au
cours de sa vie la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
va aussi tourner autour de l' esclavage
mais de manière moins évidente
vous verrez que la femme dont on va
parler à leur parcours singulier surtout
malgré elle je les découvertes grâce à
son biopic
et si elle n'a pas accompli de choses
grandioses durant sa vie elle m'a marqué
par son destin à part et par les
implications indirectes qu'elle a eu
dans la lutte contre l' esclavage en
angleterre à la fin du xviiie siècle
bref j'apprécie beaucoup cette femme
mais j'espère que vous l'apprécierez
aussi les détails de la naissance de
didot sont floues on connaît son père
john lindsay jeune capitaine du hms kent
il est basé dans les caraïbes et c'est
là qu'il rencontre maria bell qui était
apparemment esclaves à bord d'un navire
espagnol
on sait très peu de choses sur elle il
n'en existe aucun portrait et même s'il
semblerait que john kinsella prennent
comme concubine
on peut s'interroger sur le consentement
et les rapports de domination dans cette
histoire bref en 1761 et didot elisabeth
belle qui porte le nom de deux reines
celle d'angleterre et celle de carthage
john lindsay rentrer en angleterre en
1765 avec sa fille et apparemment sa
concubine mais ils décident de se marier
en 1768 avec une anglaise un peu plus
digne de son rang
maria bell rentre donc dans les caraïbes
et didot est confiée à l'oncle de son
père
cet oncle seller de william murray
premier compte de mansfield et leurs
chiffres de la justice royale
un homme important donc considéré comme
l'un des plus grands réformateurs de la
justice anglaise le droit anglais étant
fortement basée sur la jurisprudence
autant dire que ces décisions ont de
l'importance et on reviendra là dessus
par la suite l'homme handfield et sa
femme n'ont pas d'enfants il accueille
donc didot qui grandit accalmie traps
avec sa cousine elisabeth murray dont la
mère est décédée
la situation de 10,2 à cannes woodhouse
est ambiguë en tant que fils d'esclave
le droit veut qu'elle en soit une aussi
bien que le testament de leur manche
field en 1793 confiant sa liberté et en
face son héritière elle est éduquée au
même titre que sa cousine et fait
pleinement partie de la famille mais ne
mange pas avec les invités alors
rejoignez la soirée plus tard au moment
du café tenir compagnie à saku
on peut admettre qu'au delà de sa
couleur sa bâtardise et joue un rôle
dans ces exclusions temporaires car du
reste sont donc le semble beaucoup
l'aimer et offre des biens et des
vêtements coûteux james beattie un
philosophe écossais la décrit comme une
fille noire d'environ 10 ans qui était
en angleterre depuis six ans et qui non
seulement parlé avec l'articulation et
l'accent d'une native mais répéter aussi
de la poésie avec un degré d'élégance
qui aurait fait l'admiration de
n'importe quel enfant enlevé de son âge
en grandissant didot s'occupe de la
basse-cour et de la laiterie de kenwood
une occupation normale pour les jeunes
d'haïti de son époque mais elle s'occupe
aussi les correspondances de son oncle
ce qui est plus inhabituel et témoigne
de son éducation et de la confiance
qu'ils lui accordent ils l'appellent
pour cela bien plus cher que ce qu'il
pourrait payer ans secrétaire dans la
notice nécrologique de john l'insee qui
décède en 1788
il est dit qu'il a laissé une fille
naturelle une mulâtresse qui a été élevé
pratiquement depuis l'enfance dans la
famille de leurs demandes fields est
dont les aimables disposition et
accomplishments lui ont gagné le plus
grand respect de la part de la famille
et des visiteurs de sa seigneurie en
1779 laure mandeville commande un
portrait de didot et de sa cousine
elisabeth auprès du peintre david martin
il s'agit d'un portrait de famille
typique de l'époque à l'exception près
que didot et noir la plupart du temps
dans les portraits les femmes noires
sont souvent des servantes représentés
dans les poses de soumission ici le
tableau aussi entre les ambiguïtés didot
elisabeth posent ensemble la marque
elizabeth bowes sur didot témoignent de
leur affection
mais la peinture a longtemps simplement
été nommé les dix elisabeth murray la
tenue de didot est plus travaillé que
celle de sa cousine mais aussi plus
exotiques et dix bêtes porte un livre
symbole de culture tandis que didot
porte un plateau de fruits qui pourrait
rappeler ses origines coloniale ou même
refléter une possible servitude didot
est représentée vivent en mouvement
alors qu'elisabeth apparaît plus passive
et bien comme il faut on ne sait pas si
le doigt que didot pointe vers son
visage on voit à sa couleur
son sourire la peinture est maintenant
exposée au scot palace j'ai eu la chance
de revoir lors de l'un de mes voyages en
écosse et malgré les différences entre
les deux cousines
il s'agit d'un cas unique pour le xviiie
siècle où une jeune fille noire pause à
égalité avec une lady blanche après la
mort de leur romance field en 1793
on connaît moins l'avis de didot elle
épouse john d'avignon un régisseur
d'origine française ils ont deux jumeaux
en 1795 et un troisième enfant en 1800
ballmer en 1804 à l'âge de 43 ans on
ignore les causes de ce décès prématurés
et son dernier descendant meurt en 1975
didot a surtout été rendu célèbre par
son portrait unique pour l'époque un
biopic sur sa vie est sortie en 2013
ainsi que plusieurs livres et pièces de
théâtre
parmi ces pièces on trouve laide justice
biden et d'africaines cargo qui
s'attarde sur des périodes très
particulière de la vie de lido celle où
son oncle fut amené à juger des procès
sur l'esclavagé c'est probablement pour
cela qu'on se souviendra le plus de
didot bien que né dans des conditions
particulières une époque où sa couleur
et ses origines la mettait à part elle
n'a pas accompli de hauts faits comme
certaines gentes dames bad ass dont j'ai
pu parler mais son influence sur son
oncle l'a5 affection que son oncle avait
pu elle a joué un rôle décisif dans les
deux affaires qui vont suivre
le premier procès a lieu en 1772 il
s'agit de la sphère somerset versus you
heart se massaient tête un esclave
acheté en virginie en 1749 parle chance
tu vois il le suit dans tous ses voyages
jusqu en 1769 stuart seront en
angleterre la summer cette rencontre des
personnes impliquées dans le mouvement
anti esclavagiste notamment des
personnes noires libre et décide de
s'enfuir en 1771
il est repris l'estuaire prévoit de
l'envoyer dans les caraïbes pour le
vendre mais ses nouveaux amis réclame
une ordonnance d'habeas corpus afin
qu'il soit présenté devant la cour
l'augmentent fils prend alors la
décision de faire libérer
somerset en déclarant que la situation
d'esclaves est d'une telle nature
qu'elle n'a pu être instituée pour
aucune raison morale ou politique mais
uniquement par une loi promulguée qui
reste en vigueur longtemps après que la
raison l'occasion et les circonstances
même où elle a été créée ont disparu de
la mémoire cette situation et si odieuse
que rien ne peut être invoqué pour la
soutenir sinon la loi quelle que soit
les inconvénients qui pourront être la
conséquence de ma décision
il m'est impossible de dire que cette
situation est permise ou approuvés par
la loi de l'angleterre
et donc ce noir doit être considérée
comme libre il ajoute à cela que justice
soit faite
même si les cieux doivent s'effondrer
cette décision est un choc énorme
puisqu'il n'existait pas de loi
justifiant explicitement l'esclavagé en
angleterre leur demande suite considère
qu'un esclave en fuite ne peut être
remis à son propriétaire
de plus la loi anglaise ne permet à
aucun contrat d'être valide sans le
consentement de la personne
sa décision fait jurisprudence à partir
de cette date puisque la rage est abolie
dans les faits sur les territoires de
l'angleterre et de l'époque et concerne
environ 15000 personnes qui sont libérés
immédiat certains restent au service de
leurs anciens maîtres ont tant
qu'employé rémunérés malheureusement
l'arrêté somerset ne concerne pas le
reste de l'empiré britannique dans
lequel le trafic d'esclaves continue
jusque 1807 et l'esclavagé est aboli
définitivement en 1833
on ignore à quel point les liens entre
leurs mains field et didot ont pu
influencer sa décision mais on peut
supposer que son affection pour cette
nièce dont le statut sur le sol anglais
était lui-même un certain étant fils
d'esclave a pu peser sur la balance
le deuxième procès concerne le massacre
du zinc le zinc est un navire
esclavagiste néerlandais qui se livrent
au commerce triangulaire à partir de
1777 jusqu'à être capturés par les
anglais au large de l'afrique en 1781
il est alors rachetée par william
grayson un gros esclavagiste de
liverpool dont les navires ont
transporté au total 58 1201 africains
vers l'est
eric le zinc est donc acheté avec sa
cargaison les esclaves et est assurée
jusqu'à 8000 livres sterling soit la
moitié de leur valeur environ le reste
étant supporté par le propriétaire
ça aura son importance par la suite le
navire qui l'afrique commandé par l'ue
collingwood jeune capitaine et ancien
chirurgien de navires et steve agissent
dans ces navires le rôle des chirurgiens
étaient souvent de déterminer qui vivait
et qui mouraient ça aussi ça aura son
importance par la suite le zoo on doit
aller vendre les 442 escale à son bord
en jamaïque il ne s'arrête pas à tobago
pour reprendre de l'eau première erreur
et loupe la jamaïque en la confondant
avec saint-domingue
le capitaine se rend compte de son
erreur environ 500 kilomètres plus tard
alors que le surpeuplement la
malnutrition et les maladies ont déjà
tué 62 esclaves
le problème est que si les esclaves
bourré de maladie ou de mort naturelle
en mer le propriétaire ne recevaient
aucune indemnisation de la part des
assureurs l'équipage décide donc de
jeter les esclaves malades par dessus
bord puisque l'assurance ouvrirait alors
ses pertes au nom de l' varie d'eau en
effet il ne restait alors que quatre
jours d'eau sur le navire d'après les
marins sur les jours qui précèdent
l'arrivée en jamaïque 132 africains sont
jetés par dessus bord prétendument pour
économiser l'eau et sauver le reste de
la cargaison seul 208 esclaves arrive en
jamaïque et le capitaine du navire
malade lui aussi meurent dans les trois
jours
black réalisateur qui disait le
propriétaire du zoo ont fait alors une
demande aux assureurs pour compenser ces
pertes mais ceux ci refusent
un premier procès à lui en 1783 présidée
par laurence film qui conclut que tu
essaies esclaves étaient légales au vu
des circonstances puisque les esclaves
sont considérés comme une cargaison
n'ayez aucun doute bien que cela puisse
beaucoup choqué que la faire des
esclaves est la même que si des chevaux
avaient été jetés par dessus bord la
question était il y avait-il absolue
nécessité de les jeter par dessus bord
afin de sauver le reste et le jury était
de l'opinion que c'était le cas un
esclave affranchi ou l'aude haïkus est à
nos portes alors la faire à la
connaissance de l'activiste anti
esclavagiste grandes villes sharp qui
demande à poursuivre l'équipage en
justice pour meurtre
une nouvelle audience a lieu le seul
témoin à paraître et robert stop ce qui
était à l'époque passagers à bord du
ring il affirmé qu'il y avait une
absolue nécessité ajouté
les esclaves par dessus bord mais
l'épreuve inverse commencent à
s'accumuler le journal du zinc et perdu
depuis son arrivée au jamaïque comme par
hasard mais on rapporte plus tard qu'il
restait 1900 litres d'eau à bord à ce
moment là de plus il y aurait eu de
fortes pluies le dernier jour du
massacre ce qui aurait permis à tout le
monde d'arriver en jamaïque sains et
saufs
cette fois les assureurs s'appuie sur
ses arguments pour dire que l'équipage
du zinc a commis des meurtres que rien
ne justifie ils soutiennent que
collingwood voulait juste se faire de
l'argent en réparant son erreur d'avoir
dépassé la jamaïque mhand fils de
demande à nouveau procès et ont conclu
que les assureurs ne sont pas
responsables des pertes résultant des
actions de l'équipage du zinc
malheureusement et bien que les
abolitionnistes lutte pour cela aucun
des membres de l'équipage est poursuivi
pour deux meurtres
le procès reste un procès sur
l'indemnisation de la marchandise et les
juges ne se prononce pas sur le
caractère humain ou non des esclaves
toutefois le massacre du zinc devient un
symbole du mouvement abolitionniste
britannique
la society for des effectifs globaux des
abolitionnistes de fairchild est fondée
en 1787 la traite des esclaves et
réglementer une première fois en 1788 et
en 1791 une nouvelle loi interdit aux
compagnies d'assurances de rembourser
des propriétaires de bateaux dans le cas
où les esclaves sont jetés par dessus
bord j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu
comme je vous le disais didot n'a rien
fait d'exceptionnel en soi
elle a cependant eu un parcours
singulier et ans métis parmi la noblesse
anglaise
j'avais envie de parler d'elle parce
qu'il ne me semble pas qu'ils aient
toujours besoin d'avoir une vie hors
norme pour qu'on parle de soins tant
qu'amatrice d'histoire culturelle et de
micro histoire je voulais parler de
cette vie pour ce qu'elle est et une vie
elle m'a aussi permis de déborder un peu
sur les débats à propos de l'esclavagé à
la fin du xviiie siècle ce qui est un
bonus non négligeables comme c'était le
premier épisode depuis cet été c'est à
dire depuis un peu longtemps vous fait
les petits rappels habituel vous pouvez
me suivre sur facebook twitter j'ai
aussi un compte instagram même si
et pas toujours des choses en rapport
avec la chaîne vous pouvez si vous aimez
cette vidéo la partagez vous abonner et
vous pouvez également contribué à la
réalisation de ces vidéos donnant
quelques pièces sur tipi ou sur your
type
je rappelle également parce que ça vient
de sortir littéralement que j'ai écrit
un livre puis se trouve ici mais qui se
trouve aussi dans toutes les librairies
de france est d'ailleurs peut-être
bref voilà à bientôt
[Musique]
on
oh